hello and welcome to the section on
boolean classification
so we've already seen the core idea
we have a target variable which is
categorical
which we embed as
representatives in euclidean space
and in the boolean classification case
we will embed them
in a one-dimensional euclidean space the
reals
as plus or minus one so true might embed
plus one and false
to minus one and then we use regularized
empirical risk minimization to fit
with various loss functions and
regularizers
and then we use the name and pearson
metric
with our choice of kappa to express our
preference for
false negative and false positives and
we can validate
using that as our performance metric
and of course when kappa is one this
reduces to
the sum of the false negative rate and
the false positive rate which is the
error rate
now i want to look now in more detail at
possible loss functions
that one uses for boolean classification
now here y can only take values
minus one or one and so
really there are only two
scalar loss functions
so normally when we think about a loss
function
we have a function
which is a function of y and y hat
and the loss function is going to be
small or zero when y is equal to y hat
so along this line
and it's going to be increasing
as we move away from that line
but in our case y only takes two
values and so there's y equal to 1
and y equal to minus 1.
and so i've got a function which in
theory is a function of the entire plane
the loss function
l of y and y hat and y
but really it just takes two possible
values
for y and so i really only evaluate
the function along this line and along
that line
and along that line the function is l of
y hat 1 and along this line
it's l of y hat minus 1.
now we might call them something else we
might call this
um equal to l
a of y hat and this
l b of y hat just to be explicit that
even though we write them with two
arguments
they really are both functions on
one dimensional space the space of y hat
and when we look at what this function l
a or l y hat
is it tells us how much y hat irritates
us when y
is one and the other one l b tells us
how much y hat irritates us when y
is minus one and we would look for
this this function here to be small
at y-hat is 1 and increasing
away and similarly this function should
be small
at y hat is -1 and increasing away
and that sounds reasonable based on our
intuition
for loss functions in two variables
but actually that's not quite what we
want
for boolean classification and the
reason is
is that if y hat if
y is one then
we would like a y hat that unembeds
to give us 1 also
and that means that any y hat which is
positive
should give us a low loss
and similarly when y is
minus one we'd like a y hat that
unembeds to minus one
and so any y hat that's negative should
give us
a small loss and so what we really want
is we want this l
a function over here we want it to be
small
when y hat is positive we want it to be
small here
and growing in this direction
and we would like this function to be
small here
and growing in that direction
and so we've got to look at two
functions that kind of behave in the
opposite way
l of y hat one we'd like to be
large when y hat is positive
is one y hat is negative and small and y
hat's positive
l of y hat minus one we'd like to be
small
when y hat is negative and large when y
hat's positive
the way we're going to get this is we're
going to define a penalty function
p and we'll have l of y hat minus 1
be just p of y hat and we'll have l of y
hat 1 be p of minus y hat
now in order to get the property
that false positives and false negatives
irritate us different amounts we're
going to scale one of those
so in fact we'll have l of y hat 1
be p of y hat and l of
y hat 1 be kappa times
p of minus y hat
now let's look at our favorite loss to
date
the square loss function
now if we had
a loss function which
was 1
whenever we chose the wrong answer
and 0 whenever we chose the right answer
well that would be
this loss function right here
and the square loss function is this
purple blue curve here
that's for the case when y is minus one
here i've scaled on the right hand side
everything by kappa
so here kappa is two and so
i've got a loss function which is 2
when i've got an ideal loss function
which is 2
when y hat is negative and 0 when y has
positive
and i've got the square loss function
here
and well it does satisfy some properties
that we like
in particular uh when y ha
when y is minus one the loss
is large when y hat is positive
over here
use a different color
yeah and similarly when
y is 1 the loss is
large when y hat is negative which is
what it should be
and then we have the part where the
square loss lets us down
the square loss also becomes large
over here where it should
in fact be small where we'd like a loss
to be small
because any y hat
which is negative should earn us a small
loss
when the true y is minus one because any
y hat that's negative is it going to
unembed
to a y hat value of minus 1
which is exactly y and the same over
here
when y is 1. the square loss grows again
and that's not the property that we want
on the plus side of course the resulting
erm problem is a least squares problem
and so
it's easy to solve
now there's another loss function that
we might consider and that's the name
and pearson loss and here it is this is
our ideal
loss function so this is the loss
function
which is
1 when y hat is going to embed to the
wrong value
and 0 when y hat is going to embed to
the right value
and we scale that by kappa when y
is 1. and as a result
the name and pearson loss is
the loss such that when we evaluate
the empirical risk
well what's going to happen we're going
to score one point
for every time y is minus one
and y hat is
one and we're going to score kappa
points
every time y is one and y hat
is minus -1 and so
it will equal to kappa times the false
negative rate
plus the false positive rate which is
exactly the
name and pearson performance metric that
we defined before
and so this is the ideal loss function
for any particular kappa use this as a
loss function
and uh
do empirical risk minimization with this
with this loss function
and the empirical risk will be exactly
our desired performance metric
that's a good thing but the unfortunate
thing is that it's actually very hard to
minimize empirical risk
with the name and pearson loss and the
reason for that is
twofold one
is that it has discontinuities
at the origin and
those discontinuities make many
algorithms
for solving empirical risk minimization
not work well
the other is that the derivative
is zero everywhere else
and that's another feature that makes
empirical risk minimization algorithms
not work well if the derivative is zero
then if we've got a particular predictor
and we change its parameters slightly
then
what's going to happen is that the value
of
the empirical risk is probably not going
to change
because we're going to have we're going
to move our resulting y
hats say from here to here
and in both cases we're going to earn
this exactly
the same empirical risk
and so it's hard to have an algorithm
which is based upon
small changes to theta
and searching over small changes for
theta
how it's hard to have such an algorithm
work when one has a loss function
which has zero derivatives everywhere
um so instead we don't use the name and
person loss and in fact we get better
performance
if we use different loss functions and
those different loss functions not only
give us better performance but actually
also
easier to minimize
now if the loss functions are convex
well we've already discussed how convex
optimization problems are simpler to
solve
than problems where the objective
function isn't convex
and of course we need the regularizer to
be convex too well then there's a very
efficient solution
but even if the loss function isn't
convex
it's still very useful in practice and
very commonly used
so here's a loss this is a function
called the sigmoid function
this is 1 on 1 plus e to the minus
y hat that's
this function right here
and this function is of course the flip
of it so we've replaced
y hat by minus y hat and scaled it by
kappa
and you can see that this is a nice
smooth
approximation of the name and pearson
loss
we've smoothed it out and that's dealt
with both of our problems
it's removed the discontinuity and
it's removed the
zero derivative problem
so this is a nice differentiable
approximation of the name and pearson
loss
it's not convex but nonetheless it can
work well
here is one of the most commonly used
loss functions for boolean
classification this is the logistic
loss function this is the log of one
plus e to the y hat
for the case when y is minus one
and when the case when y is one we flip
it and we scale by kappa
and you can see that well it's not the
perfect approximation
to name in pearson but it does grow in
the right direction
it's small on the left hand side and it
grows as we move to the right
and the thing it doesn't do is it
doesn't flatten out
instead it keeps on growing whereas
there's no
reason in terms of a performance metric
to
penalize a y-hat
which is very
large over one that's not very large
um as long as it's greater than zero it
will unembed to one
no matter what um
but this is convex as a result of it not
um flattening out and so it's both
differentiable and convex
um and this is very commonly used and
works very well
in practice
the other very commonly used loss
function for boolean classification
is the hinge loss and this is
the positive part of one plus y hat
when y is minus one and again the flip
and scale
when y is minus one
and so it's a function which is zero
when y
hat is less than -1 and then increases
linearly
this is convex it's not it's
differentiable almost everywhere except
at this one
point right here
and this is a very very commonly used as
well this is the other
most common choice for boolean
classification
and we might do um
we might make up our own loss function
so here's one
here is one we made up which we've
called the hubristic loss
which is a cross between the huber and
the logistic
so it behaves uh
it is constant and zero when y here is
less than minus one
it grows like a quadratic here
to uh approximate that
uh change in value from zero to one
and then it continues growing linearly
at the same rate
in order to have a smooth derivative
at the origin
now several of these classifiers are
extremely popular um
if we're using the square loss a square
regularizer that would be called a least
squares classifier
if we use the logistic loss and any
regularizer
then that's called logistic regression
and so that would be called for example
logistic regression with an l1
regularizer
if we use the hinge loss with the square
that has the rather bizarre name of the
support
vector machine and what that means is
it's regularized empirical risk
minimization with that particular loss
function
and that particular regularizer
here's an example on the left here we
have the
classifier that's generated using the
logistic loss
there's no test set here and there's no
regularization here
we've got a lot of data points and
so there's no real benefit in either of
those
um and this is just of course a toy
example
and you can see the logistic loss
gives us an error of 16
on this particular data set on the right
here we see
exactly the same data set only the
classifier has been computed with the
squared loss and we can see very similar
performance
uh in fact the only difference
is that this has slightly
smaller error rate 15
as opposed to 16 um but that's in no way
a
general conclusion just a particular
feature of this
data set um and uh
in general one expects
quite similar performance between
the different losses that one might use
for boolean classification
um sometimes the logistic loss
or the hinge loss do better
than squared loss um
but as usual the only real way to
determine that
is through validation
now this is the support vector machine
this is the hinge loss
combined with the square
regularizer and it has a peculiar
feature
that is worth observing
and it only happens in this somewhat
artificial case
and so it never really happens in
practice but it is worth at least
discussing here
and that is that if you have two
a data set where the two classes
are perfectly separable so
here we have a data set where all
of the blue points are up here
and all of the red points are down here
and so
our classifier our predictor is doing
perfectly it's getting
zero training
risk and um
but it has an additional feature and
that is
that the ah
that's this line
and this line
and those lines are the
lines in x space where
theta transpose x is plus or minus one
so c to transpose x is one maybe here
and theta transpose x is minus one
maybe here or maybe the other way around
depending on which points are are one
and which points are minus one
now uh why should that be the case
now the reason that's the case is as
follows
is that the the theta transpose x is one
line is
perpendicular to the direction
that theta points in so theta here is a
vector and it points
in this direction in which case that's
theta transpose x is one
right there now what happens if i make
theta larger well that means that theta
transpose x is one
is going to move in a bit and similarly
theta transpose x is minus 1 is also
going to move in a bit
towards the origin and
um now if i evaluate
what the predictor at my data points
well the predictors at the data points
gives me y hat
and y hat is theta transpose x so
all of these points have a theta
transpose x value
have a y hat value which is greater
than one and all of these points
have a y hat value
which is less than -1
and so because if i look at this loss
function here
right all of the blue points which have
a y-hat value of greater than one
are going to give me zero
in my loss and then if i look at this
plot here for the loss for the red
points all of my red
data points have a y hat value of less
than -1
and so they're also going to give me
zero loss
and so as long as theta is sufficiently
large and pointing vaguely in this
direction
i'll end up with exactly zero empirical
risk
now what's happening is that here we've
got the square
regularizer and so that's
a penalty on the size of theta
and so by minimizing the empirical risk
plus lambda times
the norm of theta we're going to try and
make theta small
and so the best that can happen is that
we make theta
sufficiently well
so depending on the value of lambda
right
for some values of lambda we will find
that the right thing to do
is to make theta as small as we can
but still keep the loss the total loss
zero that's exactly what's happened here
is that when we make theta small
the smallest we can make theta
and yet have a loss of zero is when the
theta transpose x is one line
has moved up right the way up against
this
this one data point right there it's a
blue data point
and the corresponding theta transpose x
is minus one line
has moved up against these data points
which are right here on the boundary
and so the theta vector
it is a normal vector
to the boundary
between the two classes and its
magnitude
is equal to 1 over
half the margin
so that's the margin half width
and it that the distance is equal to
one over the norm of theta
again this is a very peculiar special
case that you never see in practice
because
you know you don't have interesting
problems
where the class is perfectly separate
let's look now at a more practical
example
this example is the australian
weather where what we have
is we have data collected at
many different weather stations across
australia
and at each of those weather stations
we've collected
attributes of the weather such as
temperature pressure
humidity wind and so on
and this data was collected over 10
years from 2007 through
2017 and consists of 142
000 or so records
and the objective we have today is that
given
this data predict whether or not it will
rain tomorrow
and so included in
this data is uh rainfall
and the target variable is whether or
not
it rained the next day
now each if we look at all of these data
records though it turns out there are
quite a few
uh missing entries in the data
and so what we've done is we've gone
through each of the records of the data
and any record that has any field
missing at all
has been removed and so once one does
that one only ends up with 112 000
or so records which is still a
substantial amount of data
we will see later in the class how to
fill in uh missing uh values
in in the data set but for now we've
just removed them
and this data of course we didn't
collect ourselves this data is
from kaggle there's a link here
and you can go there and get the data
yourself
and play with it
uh now the uh the fields in the data in
each record
uh there's a bunch of numeric fields
those are
um here listed now
the way this data is collected is that
it's daily
data and so at each of the different
sites there are 44 different sites
there's a record collected each day and
that
measures attributes of the day's weather
at that site
so for example the minimum temperature
and the maximum temperature are the
minimum temperature the maximum
temperature over that day
and a day starts at 9 am and ends at 9
a.m
similarly we have rainfall which is
total rainfall over the day
the wind gusts speed the wind speed at 9
00 am the wind speed at 3 pm
there's humidity at 9 am and the
humidity at 3 pm
the pressure at 9 am and the pressure at
3pm the temperature at 9am and the
temperature at 3pm
these are all numeric fields of course
they're all in different units
and we will embed them and standardize
them
we also have categorical fields we have
the
location as i said there are 44 possible
locations
each of the wind speeds has an
associated wind direction
and those are the 16 campus points
things like east southeast um
and uh we also have a field which is
whether or not it rained today
at that location which is either yes or
no
and there's one more final field in the
data and that is the
date on which the record was taken
so let's take a look at some of this
data because there are over 100 000
records we're only looking at a small
two percent random sample of the data
just to get a feel for it
and just looking at a couple of the
features here so here we have the
minimum temperature plotted on this axis
and the maximum temperature plot on this
axis
and we've plotted in blue those points
for which
there was rain the next day and read
those points in which there was no rain
the next day
and you can see that there is some
indication here
um over here that's uh
over here we're getting much more
chance of rain the next day than over
here
and uh and so the data does indicate
that although by the no means is there a
clear separation
now over here we've looked at the 3pm
temperature
and the 3pm pressure and we can see
again that when both of those are small
there's a chance of rain tomorrow
when both of those are large there's
much less chance of rain tomorrow
now where we embedded the data well we
have 12 numerical fields
and those are just embedded as they are
via the identity map
each one of those wind speeds is
associated with wind direction
uh which we embed as one hot
uh whether one there's rain today that's
simply a boolean categorical so we embed
it as -101
it turns out that the date and the
location fields actually did not improve
the
uh performance after validation and so
we simply removed those
um we standardized we had the constant
feature
how does this work out well there are 12
numerical fields
there are three times 16 uh
one hots and so that's uh
48 plus 12 that's 60 and then there's
rain today so there's 61
and then there's the constant feature
and that gives us 62
dimensional x
the target variable is y which is simply
a boolean categorical
whether it rains tomorrow or not and
that's uh
i simply embed it as -101
now here we're going to use the logistic
loss which we've seen before
when y is minus one the loss of y hat is
log
one plus e to the y hat and similarly
when y is one it's kappa times log one
plus e to the minus y hat and we use a
linear predictor
and we use square regularization
now we randomly split into an 80 20
training and test
sets it turns out when you do this
that the
training error and the test error are
so the training empirical risk and the
test empirical risk are extremely close
and as a result one only needs a very
small amount of regularization
and there's no point sweeping over
regularization because there's no dip in
uh in the test loss
to be gained and so as it does we just
fix
the regularization amount to a very
small fixed
amount something like 10 to the minus 5
for lambda
and so here we've plotted the operating
characteristic the rock curve
and um you can see that there's a red
curve
and a blue curve and both of them are
pretty much on top of each other the
minimum probability of error
point on the rock curve is right about
here
that's the minimum probability of our
classifier
and it achieves a
false negative rate of about point zero
eight
and a false positive rate of about point
zero eight so a total probability value
of about
sixteen percent
uh which is pretty good uh it's worth
comparing also with this point down here
that's a classifier which achieves an
error rate
of 22 percent um
and the way it does that is by always
predicting that it will not rain
tomorrow
and that's because the data itself
contains
about 22 percent days
with rainfall and the remaining 78 of
days have no rain
um and so this is a very simple
predictor which is doing uh reasonably
well
with a prediction with an error rate of
22 percent um of course it's very
trivial
and we that's really the baseline which
we have to do better
which we have to improve upon and so
we're achieving 16
which is a significant improvement over
22 percent
uh it would be nice to do better than
that but with
uh the linear predictor that we're using
uh this seems to be the best achievable
now if we
look at the
minimum error predictor and we look
at its parameter vector theta
and then we can plot here the components
of theta theta i against i
this says absolute value of the ui is
not of course the absolute value it's
just theta i
um and
what we see is some large values and
some small values
these large values here don't matter
because there are 16
of them and those
16 entries of x are the one
hot embedded values for wind deer
at nine am and because those columns
uh are one hot embedded
they sum up to one and so this is just
equivalent to
a constant term in the predictor and
that's just the way the
the training worked out we could simply
subtract off
this term and add it to the theta 1 term
and uh it would give us an equivalent
predictor
so those aren't the significant thing
some interesting things are
important uh this and this
this is the pressure
at 3 pm and this is the pressure
at 9 00 am and so we've got a predictor
here
that depends very strongly
on the difference between the pressure
at 9am and the pressure at 3pm
and so if the pressure is falling
so 3pm pressure is much less than 9 am
pressure
then that is a strong predictor of
rainfall and of course this is a very
well known phenomenon in the weather
that rapidly falling pressure indicates
that a storm is coming
the other features here that are
significant are
this is of course just the constant term
so it's not really a feature
and this one right here is the wind gust
speed
this one here is humidity it's vpn
and these two are min temp and max temp
since those are the significant features
we can simply say let's
retrain our predictor using only those
six features
the min temp the max temp the wind gust
speed humidity at 3 pm
pressure at 9 am and pressure at 3 pm
and if you do that then you end up with
a classifier that achieves a probability
of error on the test set of about 16 and
a half percent
which is basically the same as the
classifier we had with all of these
features
and so the rest of these features
are irrelevant at predicting rainfall
at least with the current linear
predictor
so it's possible that one could do
better maybe by using a more complicated
predictor such as a neural network
predictor
maybe by using some more sophisticated
feature engineering
combining features and this is simply of
course a first
foray into designing a predictor to
predict
rainfall
okay so next section
we will talk about classification
where there are more than two classes
multi-class classification
and we will see the appropriate form
of losses to use in that case